the White House Correspondents
Association says critics of Saturday
night's annual gala have a reason to be
upset
the group says an edgy monologue by a
comedian Michelle wolf was quote not in
the spirit of its mission wolf made
jokes about the media and the president
but her mocking of White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders caused the
strongest backlash mr. Trump called wolf
filthy vladimir duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn is here with the
response from critics and supporters
vlad good morning a good morning the
White House Correspondents Association
builds its annual dinner as a way to
raise money for journalism scholarships
and to honor the work of Washington
reporters but it's the events featured
entertainer that normally grabs the
following morning's headlines some say
this year's host hit new extremes
it's 2018 and I am a woman so you cannot
shut me up unless you have Michael Cohen
wire me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars Michelle wolf didn't pull any
punches during her 19 minute routine her
toughest jobs seemed to aim at White
House staffers including press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders I think she's
very resourceful like she burns facts
and then she uses that Ash to create a
perfect smokey eye some female
journalists said Wolf unfairly
criticized Sanders physical appearance
calling the routine deplorable I have to
say I'm a little star-struck
I love you as aunt Lydia and The
Handmaid's Tale others including many
prominent comedians came to wolf's
defense calling her hilarious and funny
speaking on CNN the next morning White
House Correspondents Association
president Margaret olive stood by her
decision to feature wolf do you think
she crossed a line I think that she
brought to the night what she thought
was important to say and that her goal
may not have been press unity and
everyone rallying around the room to
support journalism in a conversation
with CBS this morning Saturday wolf
previewed her routine company shouldn't
be about like what you want to hear it
should be about what you didn't know you
wanted to hear on Twitter President
Trump who was not in attendance for the
second year in a row called the event an
embarrassment to everyone associated
with it
dinner to rest or start over Donald
Trump he also made reference to the 2011
dinner where he had his own
uncomfortable experience being roasted
by President Obama no one is happier no
one is prouder to put this birth
certificate matter to West than the
Donald and that's because he can finally
get back to focusing on the issues that
matter why did we fake the moon landing
Taleb says the White House
Correspondents Association does not
review the comedian's monologue before
it's delivered Wolff defended herself on
social media saying the Sanders jokes
were about her despicable behavior she
later posted a picture of herself on
Instagram saying she is not in the
spirit of the mission well they need to
look clearly about what the mission of
the White House Correspondents
Association and I think part of it
includes civility and jokes are fine and
humor is fine but there are some stuff
that's below the belt yeah also if if
one side thinks that were too cozy with
the people in the administration and the
other side thinks we're giving a
platform to attacks that are vulgar it
turns out we're doing something that is
not our core job which is offending both
sides not in the service of our jobs so
maybe they need to rethink it is about
scholarships right that's what the
dinner is about and that gets completely
lost in the course of all of this so
maybe it's time for recalibration indeed
thank you